All right, we're recording. Welcome to today's Zoom call. It is 321 18. It's the first day of spring, I believe. If we look outside here, it's 92 and sunny in Minnesota.
There's people sunbathing out front because I can see the beach. And if you've been to my office, you know, I'm not telling the truth. It's freezing.
It's snowy and it's it's Minnesota. So we just get used to it and enjoy it. But I can't complain because I was in Hawaii last week. And not everybody can say that. So I'm blessed that it was an enjoyable vacation and I'm glad to be back.
So today's Zoom call we're going to start by going over the questions that were emailed in and then we'll open it up to any other questions that you folks may have, you know, the Zoom call.
So the first question that got emailed in is going to a car practice that's in the nutrition and he told me that I should start drinking protein to help stop muscle loss.
And because of my weight loss, what's your feeling about this? And what should I do about it? Should I use a protein powder? What should I do?
So we do have protein powders that we utilize in our office, thereby this company, US enzymes, there's a chocolate and a vanilla, they're very tasty. And the reason why that we advocate for these protein powders if someone is going to use protein is that it is a low glutamine protein.
And it has a lot of enzymes in it and it has a prebiotic and a probiotic in it. So it's a really great source of some protein has a plant based protein low glutamine exactly what you want for as a cancer patient.
And this is the protein product that you'd want to use if you're going to use a protein product, but I did say one word there that's a very large word that only has two letters if so not everybody needs to use a protein powder.
Matter of fact, very few people need to use a protein powder. And the thought process that I need to stop muscle waste by adding a protein powder is not exactly true.
So there are some thoughts out there that if I have muscle waste, I need to increase by protein consumption because protein is what builds up muscle because muscle is made of protein.
And there was a question on the Facebook this last week that I'm sure most of you looked at because there was a lot of responses on it.
And that was what do I tell people if I'm on a low protein diet and I'm trying to build up muscle and not lose muscle, what do I tell people in my comment was look at many different types of vegetarian animals out there that are not eating animal protein in our very strong and muskily like I said on the Facebook post.
And my point is always look at the silverback gorilla they tend to be kind of muskily and they eat a complete vegetarian diet. So to say that we need protein sources, especially animal protein sources, is is a little bit silly.
Now we are getting protein in plant sources as well. And this is I believe I can't remember if you look at the back of this, I think it's there's a pee at a hip and such protein in this that's what this protein is made up of. So we don't need animal protein, we certainly don't want animal protein as a protein source with cancer patient.
So if you're going to use a protein powder, this would be the one to do. But again, just by taking a protein powder does not mean you're going to gain muscle mass, you should be, you know, getting most of your protein through a good vegetable based diet as well. So not everybody needs this.
I take this one once in a while just because I like what it tastes like so, but I tend to only take that, you know, couple once maybe once or so a week. So I don't take that on a regular basis, but that's this is the protein powder. I think is really the only one that I found on the market that meets my standards for cancer patient as this one.
The next question I've been doing the Budway protocol for nine months and I love it. I use the aunties or get it kind of cheese at Barley's flax oil. That's an organic cold press flax oil.
Can I add some fresh ginger and kind of apple and cinnamon, but I noticed some white specks in my stool. So obviously I'm not fully digested it.
Plus it makes, I think it makes me somewhat constipated. So first of all, if you're noticing white specks in your stool, you're looking too closely at your stool.
If you're looking, if you see white specks in your stool, that doesn't mean you're not completely digesting the the flax, you know, it could be something completely different than that.
Just because the cottage cheese is white and you're noticing white specks, it could be something different that that's in your stool. So I wouldn't jump to the conclusion that you're not fully digesting that.
However, that is a dairy product and it is difficult to digest. That's why what are the reasons why we have most of you off of dairy is because of it's difficulty digesting.
Now, I understand the philosophy and I even adhere to the philosophy that when you blend flax oil and omega six blood fatty acid to the cottage cheese it changes the protein structure of the dairy products.
So it could it could it could be well tolerated by most people that even if they have a dairy sensitivity and it doesn't create the same response as far as the amtorpath way.
And I understand that philosophy and that's why I still allow people to do the mudwink protocol, even if I'm taking them off of dairy.
But still you can have some digestive issues with it. So her ascertaination here, the next sentence would a digestive enzyme for dairy be something to try is a very wise statement there.
So that would be the next step. So if you feel like it is because of improper digestion of the dairy product that yes, using a digestive enzyme, maybe the thing to try.
And I can post on the Facebook page and then prepare it at a time here, what kind of digestive enzymes would be probably best.
I don't think it would interfere with the action of the mudwink protocol. So I think that would be a good thing to do. So mudwink protocol is a quote unquote cancer killing protocol.
And I have a bunch of stuff on our website in I believe the blog section of our website that's on the resources page on the mudwink protocol so you can search for that and find some more detail on that and how to make it. I just pulled this off the internet today.
Second half of that person's questions was I'd like to put my email on the Facebook page, but she wanted to have permission before doing so. And I appreciate that. So I would ask that if you're getting maybe a little bit crossing the gray area and what you should be sharing or not sharing that Facebook like your personal information.
It would be wise that you contact us first before you do so. I have no trouble with someone putting their email on Facebook if they want that connection or saying would you please Facebook message me maybe that be a little bit more appropriate because you know, you know, as our as our Facebook group are patient only Facebook group grows.
And it just you just want to also protect yourself because though all our patients are wonderful patients. If somebody is getting a hold of one of our patients accounts and it takes your email for I just want to protect yourself. So maybe it'd be better to ask for people to private message you.
So maybe let's say let's say I want I want to communicate with other people who have total focus.
Then you might want to just post something. Hey, I'd like to communicate with other people that have total function focus. Could you please private message me if you do because I have total focus as well.
So then that would be one way to communicate and to maybe be more specific because we have a bunch of people with all sorts of different types of cancer on our page.
So it's, you know, if you're trying to communicate with a person with your type of cancer and try to develop a relationship and maybe a support system that's a little bit closer and more intimate.
Then certainly ask for that just ask him looking for somebody with press cancer or prostate cancer that would like to develop a relationship and communicate with what they're doing.
Just post that and see if you could get a response and then people can choose to respond or not to where they're at. So that's what would be my suggestion and that's what we want.
We want this Facebook group to be intimate and as it grows, you tend to lose some intimacy. So the way to develop that intimacy you get is to just have some some groups that develop some
and close this with the few people that might have your same type of situation. So go ahead and do that.
The last question was about the last Zoom call with Dr. Hallermann and it was about to derf to pathway and using the broccoli based product to enhance the gluteus thio and this person said I have a problem with histamine and gluteumates along with sensitivity to solvers that you mentioned at one of my office visits on the transfer,
so I posted a picture of the transformation pathway. That's where homocysteine is taken from.
There's a pathway up here that is your methionine pathway through these genes each one of these bubbles is a gene. So through these genes and if a person has defects on these genes, especially a CBS gene defect this can sail down here quite quickly and can cause issues with inability to
detoxify sulfates, sulfites, sulfur groups, and they could produce a lot of gluteumates in ammonia. So that could be an issue.
And the question was if they have, so because of that, they're staying away from too many cruciferous vegetables, which could contain sulfur groups, because then they can get kind of an ammonia smelly urine, because they're detoxified it that through the normal pathway.
So this that's what this person is talking about. So what about taking the broccoli product? Is that going to, is that going to cause this pathway to go faster and cause more problems.
And the belief right now and the understated that we have with patients that we're dealing with is the answers, no, it should not, because the north to pathway feeds gluteus thio through this path through a pathway that's not out here.
And it's not on this picture. So it's feeding gluteus thio to the different mode. And so that's what the sulfur of aid product that we're talking about that Dr. Hallerman was talking about with the two pathway does so you should be finding experiment.
So experiment with this product should still be okay. The answer is, yes, it should still be okay.
You do want to be careful of Dr. Hallerman might address this next week.
We're talking at length about another possible issue with getting rid of toxins, just really, really new studies that are coming out about how your liver then takes toxins out of the blood goes through what's called phase one phase two congregation and then puts the toxin into the bile duct.
So it goes into the gallbladder so it goes into the liver so it goes into the toilet and there can be other issues along that pathway.
The sulfur of aid pathway that she was talking about in the nerve to pathway that's taking place in the liver mainly and but once it is transported into the bile duct and into the gallbladder and into the colon and into the toilet.
There can be some issues in that getting it into the bile duct. So she's going to be talking about that that's called phase two and a half what she's going to be coity that term as and so look for that.
We're going to chat question here, will the clinic be when will the clinic be open in Florida it's cold out there.
I'm afraid see I'm afraid that we're going to open up this clinic in Florida nobody's going to come to Minnesota anymore and maybe that's not bad I'll just take a more permanent vacation that's great but
I don't think that I'm going to be spending a whole lot of time in Florida so Dr. Kelly is going to be so busy she's going to be calling to be cried all the time and I'm just going to take the calls.
So it's when are we going to be open in Florida the the plan right now and is our hope is is sometime this summer so our hope is really realistically August looking at.
Of course that means that we have to have a space which we don't yet so I'm calling everybody that knows anything about Florida and if you know anything about Fort Myers.
This we're looking at an area called estero which is just a little to the suburb of southern suburb of Fort Myers but eat a sprigs area.
If you know anybody that has office space for red down there and let us know so we would be happy if you had some connections so.
So answer this question no if you have defects along this pathway still using the broccoli product would be beneficial but you we do want to go slow so broccoli product the brocco up clear that is our own product now that we have out.
60 milligrams of active so for a fan in it which is a lot and we had it a lot put in because I know that people like taking less supplements so for most people one pill a day is going to be sufficient so it's that's why we created that way so that was our goal.
Next question is pros and cons of surgeries and biopsies when you have cancer in order to answer that question I had to pull up this slide again so when we talk about surgery with cancer it's all about trying to make sure we're not operating this guy right here we've had a lot of different.
Conference calls and chats and and zoom calls and slide presentations and amtore so to refresh your idea of what amtore is as amtore is your is basically your growth pathway so amtore is up regulated that means it's stimulated when growth needs to take place and healing from an injury is growth.
So if you can understand that if I cut my hand it has to scar over or I will bleed to death so it scars over actually quite quickly within a couple hours to a couple days depending on how deep that cut is now how does it do that it's not magic it does that by up regulated amtore because normally is my hand.
Looking at the back of my hand between my thumb and my first figure the web of my hand is what I'm looking at how often are those cells replaced how often are those cells replaced in my hand and my skin about once every 12 weeks so that's not really growing too fast is it but it how often are those cells replaced if I cut myself.
They're replaced about once every two minutes because it's building black a scar a wound it's healing that in a matter of a couple weeks that will depend again on how deep I cut myself will be scarred over and pretty much healed up.
Well how can it do that if it's only replacing cells once every 12 weeks well it has to tremendously up regulate this pathway this amtore pathway so that cells are replicated messenger RDA and glycolysis is up regulated and in order to do that in order to make new cells in order to create a scar wound in order to heal that tissue.
So it is when we do surgery so if I'm going to do surgery to do a biopsy or do surgery to remove a mass in my breast that I am in order to heal I have to up regulate amtore if I don't I will just bleed to death and die so it's not that we don't want to up regulate amtore if we're healing from a wound you have to.
But do we want to create a wound sometimes it's necessary so sometimes yes it's beneficial to debalk a cancer it is surgically remove the large mass there so our body can heal that and we can do all these other things to be able to heal that that.
That cancer that wound there but certainly doing surgeries that are maybe more elective surgeries might not be the best thing in what my cancer is active so if I'm in a stage of my cancer where i'm doing really well and it's everything settle down and let's say I do an IVG test in my IVG score is a 12.
And now is this a good time to have my herdeous surgery yeah that might be a good time to have a herdeous surgery right now because I do want to deal with this herdea that I have if that's caused problems by digestion I'm worried about having problems with it now is a good time to do the herdeous surgery is a good time to do is herdeous surgery what I'm not doing well with my cancer i'm feeling really fatigued i'm not feeling well I did an IVG score it's a 27.
No, probably not a good time to do herdeous surgery right now and there's probably not a lot of doctors that would do a herdeous surgery at you either but there are surgeries that people do do post cancer surgery like doing a mastectomy well that's a big surgery that's going to highly upregulate him tour which is not necessarily good for that person's cancer.
But secondly then they go and do reconstructive surgery so that's one thing if you better on me very long that's not something I'm a big fan of because that's an elective surgery and I know it affects your psyche and all this kind of stuff so we can talk about that for days but that's not maybe the best thing to do for the cancer cells that are still left so
elective surgeries possibly not so yes there's a time to go back to that question is there a time that we do surgery yes there's a time we do biopsies yes is it always the best thing to do no use have to understand you are upregulated pathway would you do that okay so there was another question that moves head what if you have no gallbladder so what if you have no gallbladder I think you was talking about the pathway back here.
That yes if you have no gallbladder and you are and the detox pathway that we're talking about with with how you get rid of toxins in your blood it's brought across the cell membrane through specific receptors in your hepatocytes or your liver cells goes through phase one phase two detoxification where it's either made an aqueous solution or it's in your blood.
But a lipid solution depending on what toxin it is it goes through another receptor site in the cell membrane to be disposed into the bile duct and it stores in the gallbladder and what if I don't have a gallbladder well then it's going to go right into your colon but it won't go into your colon the same way that if it's stored in your bile duct because if it's in your if it's in your bile duct
things go into your colon more cyclically when you eat a fat and and then it's dumped into the colon so otherwise it's going to go right into your colon.
All right so what is IBG score I'm talking about the IV gene score so the IV gene score your IV gene score is what you have to go back and watch some of the other videos the IV gene test
we've talked about at least a dozen videos and and it's the videos are posted to the Facebook and the blog about the IV gene.
Now I'm going to open up everybody and unmute everybody so please stop eating your captain crunch or the microphone and we can hear everybody.
So all right is anybody have any questions this is Sharon someone told me that there is a fly the test that test for a certain mutation
and it's both the test for people who don't process like medications and things as well as others like if you know you're taking medication for cancer or some other kind of ailment.
Your body doesn't really pass it and it doesn't work.
Okay so I get a beauty everybody at all answer that okay.
Okay so everybody's muted and what she's talking about is the MTHFR gene so I really want you to really get a good answer in this.
I want you to go onto our website right here and go to the so it's we reorganize the website a little bit go down to where it says genes tell stories
and down at the bottom of this there's a whole bunch of links here to different videos that I put together on your genes like the SNP defects and cancer this talks about different SNP defects with cancer the genes leave clues I think is the main page where it's got a whole bunch of or this is has to do with diet.
The specific SNP testing this is where it's going to have a whole bunch of videos here on your genes see all these different videos each one of these is a different video tells you what a SNP is and that that share that that G you were talking about is the MTHFR that's the the gene that is been given so much credence and there's even MTHFR websites and.
Facebook groups and everything so that's something you want to watch these videos because that pathway though it is important is probably way down on my doctor hall of its list of importance when it comes to not even cancer patients just even done cancer patients on all your genes so you really want
to get a bigger picture of your genes that just your MTHFR gene that's this gene right here it's actually the bottom gene of the folate pathway there's actually two genes in there in the MTHFR genes that that drive this pathway and feed ultimately the production of metal transfer groups right here so though MTHFR is important it's not any more important that any of these other genes
MTHFR is not the main pathway that you that you detox drugs and other things the pond one pathway in the at a tea pathway or the main pathways that you would get rid of drugs and other things including chemotherapies so there's watch those videos it would take me another couple hours just to explain that that understand those pathways that's why I made these videos
this video here I made a little over a year or so ago it's about an hour long but it goes over a lot of the gene pathways and when you get a bigger picture of all the gene pathways here's a little bit newer one that I created it's about an hour long then you'll go oh now I get the big picture that I can understand that better
but this this is not for detoxing like medications it's for like the medications you know the body absorbing them and they're working because like someone said that to me because I've been on like very many standard medications that are out there for my cancer that have you know been incredible for most people but they're not doing anything to me
yeah so watch that, watch that video, watch the video so you can get a much better idea
Dr. Connor, this is this is Deb's words anyway I'm on the fasting mimicking diet my last last month for the first three can you still do castor oil, foot bath detoxing and frequent right frequencies
yes you can still do all those three yeah the coffee in them is okay also I would say so yes okay and one more thing you hit an arc on histamine again I'm sorry I'm that's my problem anyway it's said on there you have enzyme therapy for that
high doses enzyme therapy so help lower this stimulating histamine and by flavonoids yes which ones do you recommend for that okay so I believe I tested you on that that did not work for you
but the difficult here I'm gonna be with everybody again so somebody's somebody's either in their car or you know we're getting a lot of feedback on somebody I don't know who it is
so I just gotta keep on muting people what I'm doing this so with the histamines the struggle with dealing with histamines is this is that is that it does that what would you let's just talk about cancer with histamines for a second so does the person have high histamines
and then that's a precursor for their cancer because all the studies are looking at here's this cancer patient what's their histamine level and they're finding as I wrote in that article the studies are finding that a good percentage not all but a large percentage of cancer patients
especially those ones that I wrote in that article have high histamine levels so then the question what needs to really ask if they're really being key minded is that is the cancer causing the high histamines
or is the high histamine level in the person due to some other reason at least a piece of the cause of the cancer what came first the histamine or the cancer and there's no studies on that
so as we in Dr. Hallerman and I had a very lengthy discussion today just about that very topic as you understand how histamine is degraded so the person has high histamine levels
let me see if I could show you if you really are interested in this so to me it's exciting and it's dirty but to other people it might not be but here's the pathway
so you eat food it goes through glycolysis glucose does and it makes pyruvate this guy right here now normally these pathways aren't working over here
normally pyruvate should go through the PDH enzyme and make acetyl coenzyme why because it goes into the crebs cycle to make energy now that seems dirty but this is just how your body works
so you break down sugar so you break down all carbohydrates into glucose that then break down into pyruvate your whole purpose in life so get go back and watch those genetic videos
because there are a lot there are a lot more than just your genes one of your main purposes in life is to make energy if you don't make energy you die and the one of the ways that we make energy is through glycolysis
and then through acetyl coenzyme going through the crebs cycle to make energy you need energy so cancer cells need energy so what is a cancer doing?
cancer is a cell that's in rapid replication a cell in more rapid replication needs more energy so you would think that cancer cells would be gobbling up glucose shunted it to acetyl coenzyme just like a normal cell does
and sending it through the crebs cycle because this is where you kick out a whole bunch of ATP this is where you kick out a bunch of energy
well it was discovered that many cancers don't do this and it was very strange nobody has figured out why many cancers take pyruvate and shunted down to lactate or lactic acid and that's what feeds the cancer
this is called the warberg effect you've heard of the warberg effect if you've studied anything about cancer on a warberg discovered that cancer cells and not all cancers just some will shunt glucose this way
and when we test you with kinesiology that's what we're testing you for is your cancer feeding directly off of glucose through that shunt of lactic to lactic acid
and those are the people that were putting out a very low carb diet a ketogenic diet or a ketogenic like diet
well in the discovery of genetics we discovered the PDH gene and the HIF genes so if you have HIF1 genes and PDH gene defects that in itself will slow this profit process in shunt pyruvate to lactic
long before warberg knew that genes existed he just knew that this thing took place there was no understanding to why now with the understanding of genetics and you can look at a person's PDH genes and HIF genes this shunt could be taking place
however there's a whole nother mechanism that ties with histamine that is a done this and we have to make our own little infographic about this because we are Dr. Kelly you know I just kind of just figured it out
acetyl coenzyme is essential in a process called acetylation of histamine in order to get rid of histamine so if a person has high histamine levels it gobbles up acetyl coenzyme not allowing it to go make energy through the crem cycle and it doesn't through a different process not making energy but it gets rid of histamine through a different process through acetylation of histamine
so a person with high histamine levels has got acetyl coenzyme steel I just stole that term from Dr. Halterman today so I have to give her credit the acetyl coenzyme steel where it steals acetyl coenzyme from crem cycle issues which this is supposed to make energy to get rid of histamine and that is one mechanism why people with high histamine levels have chronic fatigue
because what do you need to make what is your one one of your life goals is to make energy and if you're stealing acetyl coenzyme to get rid of histamine you're not making energy.
Well how does that fit with cancer? Well if a person with cancer has high histamine levels for another reason let's say they have high histamine levels for another purpose because they have different ABP1G defects and they can't go too deep into that so let's say they have high histamine levels they're getting the acetylene
and need for acetyl coenzyme and they're going to get acetyl coenzyme steel that will shut glucose down this way to lack the acid and feed the cancer.
So I know this gets into biochemistry nightmare here for some of you but this is the things that we're trying to figure out why it's taking place and how to intercept this
it makes some changes so we can help people that aren't getting help any other way. So there's ways that we're discovering and try to figure out how to prevent this acetylene and the acetyl coenzyme steel to block histamine and what are the things is we got to figure out how we got a lower histamine and figure out why the person has high histamine in the first place because the purpose of having high histamine is to get rid of antigens
in the tissues and the blood that shouldn't be there in the first place. So go back and read that article about histamine again. So yes, to answer your question it is probably way too many words Deb is using enzymes one way of doing this. Yes, but I believe I tested you on that.
Now you're going to be up here pretty soon and I'll test you on that again. Now we have another several other things that we're going to be utilizing to test people that are pretty inventive on ways to block this acetyl coenzyme steel and to lower histamine levels. Hopefully that answers your question. Now we're going to unmute everybody again.
Just extend on it a little further. What about if you have Candida? Does it go down the anaerobic pathway then? Yeah, so there's different things that could go down this pathway, different things that could push it down this pathway.
Not just have not just the genetic defects, but there's many things that could push it down this pathway.
Thank you.
Dr is the glucose level from you from lab work any indication of whether you're taking in too much sugar.
It can be so let me answer that. I'll mute everybody. I'm sorry I have to mute everybody. I get so much feedback from somebody's phone. I don't know who it is.
So is getting a glucose level from lab work or getting your own glucometer where you're checking your glucose level at a 12 hour fast. So that's a really good idea to do.
So a glucometer costs about $25 a target and it has about 50 strips that come with it and you can check your glucose level right when you wake up by doing a little figure prick and checking your glucose level.
So you haven't eaten for 12 hours. You're going to 12 hour fast glucose and it should be about 75 to 85 would be perfect.
Now, it's even normal to be up in the low dyes, but when you start to get into the mid dyes, it up your into what's considered this early phase.
Disglycemia, meaning inability to handle glucose. Now, if your diet is good and you're following a good whole food diet that's very low in carbs.
Now, let's say you're not on a ketogenic diet. You're on a low carb. You're eating a lot of vegetables so you are getting some carbohydrates through your vegetation.
But so you're not really coated your carbs that way, but you're not eating any sweets. You're not eating any sugar.
You're you're staying away from that. You've really changed your diet. You're still coming up with the glucose level in, you know, 105, 112 in the morning and you have no history of diabetes.
That's concerning it. There's there's many different possible pathways that that's taking place that I won't go into that now because we're already 45 minutes into this, but that is a side of
that can be a side of that I'm eating too much sugar. So, number one, if if I don't have a history of cancer, the diagnosis of diabetes is a 12 hour fasting glucose over 125.
So, but if I have a glucose, a 12 hour fasting glucose over 100, you're technically at a prediabetic state. So, we want to get that level down.
So, the first thing you would do is change your diet, get off your carbohydrates and start exercising and that would typically lower people's glucose levels.
But let's say a person is on a good diet and they're still riding high glucose levels. Well, there's a pathway made through your liver, your liver stores glycogen, which is which is lung chains of multiple glucose is linked together and that's stored in your liver.
So, normally that's released when cortisol is released. So, if a person has a high amount of stress in their life, that could be a cause of high glucose levels.
So, that's the second thing you want to look at is does the person have a lot of stress in their life?
And if the answer is yes, they're under a enormous amount of stress that could be releasing glycogen stores in the liver and causing these glucose spikes at different times.
Secondly, there's other possibilities with cancer patients too. You could be actually producing glucose by breaking down muscle through a process called glucose deogenesis.
You're actually creating glucose and that will raise glucose levels in the blood through breaking down muscle layers and we don't want that to be taking place.
So, there's multiple other pathways when you talk about high glucose levels, even having high histamine levels, having the acetyl coenzyme steel can raise glucose levels.
So, this is another possible way to raise glucose levels. So, we want to investigate that but we don't measure it, we don't know.
So, if your glucose levels are over a hundred, that's the point that it more concerns me and you're on a good diet, that's what would more concern me.
Does the opposite hold true if your levels are at a good range? Does that mean you're necessarily not eating too much sugar?
So, let's say I'm measuring my glucose levels, they're there, it's instantly in the seventies.
That would mean that, yes, you are doing a really good job of not feeding cancer through this pathway.
So, typically when you go out of ketogenic diet, you're actually training yourselves to use ketone bodies for fuel instead of glucose for fuel.
So, you could push this pathway through ketone bodies instead of through glucose and you voted at producing lactate.
So, that takes some time and it takes some effort and it's very difficult to hold to a true ketogenic diet for any length of time.
And you have to actually do a blood test to measure how many ketones a person has in their blood to see if they're really in a state of ketogenic ketosis.
But that's a difficult thing, but if you could measure your glucose levels in their measured, you know, fasty glucose levels are measured in the seventies.
You're doing a really good job of not feeding this pathway.
And you don't want to go below seven.
No, you'll be at a state of more hypoglycemia if you go below seven.
All right, did we answer more questions than you had today?
Yes, Dr. Connors, it's Lisa just one other question does the broccoli, broccoli clear, replace the other broccoli supplement.
So, the broccoli protect and the broccoli clear are almost identical.
The only difference is that the broccoli clear, we just bumped up the dose on there. So, there's 60 milligrams instead of 50.
And it's a little bit less, it turns out to be a little bit less expensive. So, that's why we switched products.
Okay.
So, broccoli clear all order.
Okay. Thank you.
All right. Well, hopefully you gain some information on tonight's call. It'll be saved and put up on Facebook in just a little bit.
I do want to let everybody know about a cancer study that we're going to be involved in with genetics.
We don't obviously have everybody's genes yet, but we're hoping to have the new test kits by next week or so.
Again, that's completely out of our control.
So, you want to talk to somebody who's frustrated about not having that just call me because I'm more frustrated than all of you.
So, it's a struggle, but it's beyond our control and we have to just go, okay, it is what it is we have to do.
Let's see that we're going to be doing what genetics and we're going to be measuring everybody's, look at everybody's genes again to refresh your memory about genes.
We're looking at all these different pathways with your genes and all these different genes times, you know, 30 really, all these different genes.
We're going to be comparing and doing some study. We're actually want to present to a international conference next fall.
Let's do itself and what genes are and nobody's ever done this study before.
What genes do cancer patients as a whole tend to have more defects in.
And then what what genes do breast cancer patients have more defects in and what genes to call the cancer patients have more defects in.
Down the list of as many different separations as we can to get as much data as we can.
Nobody's name is going to be used in this study or anything like that was pulling data, but it's going to be data that is could be really groundbreaking.
It could be really helpful for not only the treatment of cancer beyond our clinic, but but looking at preventing cancer and dealing with some of these defects prior to a diagnosis.
Because it's what's that data is out there. It's going to be really, really beneficial to then glean that data and use to how to help people before they end up getting cancer.
Because as far as I know, and I'm pretty knowledgeable about most of the alternative cancer clinics are new to out there. Nobody's doing nobody's tired of genetics.
Oh, this is going to be pretty groundbreaking. We're pretty excited about that study.
If you have questions about that, make sure you're just posted on Facebook.
Let's say though that like I had testing through the hospital genetic testing and they came up with the 20 gene that commonly would have mutations that would cause cancer.
I didn't have any of them.
They're looking at 20. We're looking at 900,000 steps.
Well, that's, that's not a title coming out of my mouth. 900,000 steps. So that's a big difference. So we're looking at a much bigger picture.
And when you go back to the website and you watch that some of that hour long video on jeans, you'll get a better idea of really what we're looking at.
And that is only really what I'm going over there is maybe a few hundred steps.
So you'll get an idea of getting a bigger one, a bigger picture of Venus.
Sounds great.
All right. So I'm going to say goodbye. Let's say it was already other comments.
Any other chance.
The illustrator. Can you hear me?
Yes.
How was your vacation?
Well, it's my vacation vacation. It was very good. Thank you.
Awesome. One question.
Yeah. Just a question. Is there an update on when you'll have the new DNA testing?
Okay. Just I just stated that that we don't know. We hope it'll be next week.
Okay.
And if you get that on that foot bath in it, it's absolutely amazing.
Oh, good.
What exactly is coming out of that?
You know, I don't know. I'm not want to say that it's all this heavy metals and junk,
but there is some of that coming out. There's toxins that come out, but it is ionization of the water as well.
So it's just some. There's some.
But if you're on a keyboard, that's an ejector there.
In a port once every three weeks or something that I'd say yes.
What time of the day is best to do that?
I don't know that there's a time of the day that's better. Some people may have a difference of opinion.
I know you might want to do it earlier, because if you are pulling out any minerals,
or something at night,
but that would be the only factor that I would think of.
If you're at son is the have a preference for time to do that one, I would say maybe the same thing,
but it's partly in for it's on us just to when you're applying to the day to do some of this.
Okay. You have preferential programs on the foot bath.
So it depends on what you're dealing with.
If you know you're dealing with having to do some of those things.
If you know you're dealing with live, do some of those kind of things.
Okay.
Most specifically this is on the right programming.
I saw like detox for different categories of detox would be under that category.
Are you talking about the foot bath programs?
Yeah, you could do the foot bath programs, you could do the detox categories.
That's exactly right.
I got to mute you Lewis, because I think you're the one that's the know it the one that's getting the feedback.
Alright, so we're going to stop right there and I'll get this video up just as soon as I can.
If you have any other questions, make sure you just ask them on the Facebook page.
And we will all try to get the answer.
Thank you.
Bye bye.
Bye.